jean paul belmondo vous êtes un des
principaux personnages de film un singe
en hiver réalisé par henri verneuil
pouvez-vous en quelques mots nous camper
votre personnage pour nous
téléspectateurs
oui en quelques mots c'est un personnage
qui vient dans ce petit pays pour
retrouver sa fille est en pension vais
surtout le sur le principe de ce
personnel c'est un personnage qui a aimé
une femme et en espagne et lui-même a
beaucoup vécu en espagne et la tendance
à boire et chaque fois qu'ils boivent
ils reparlent de l'espagne et se prend
que vous avez vu hier lapointe toréador
tous ces souvenirs sont en espagne c'est
la première fois que vous tourniez avec
jean gabin
oui vous le connaissiez avant donc aux
membres mais comment a été l'attitude de
jean gadenne il invite vous on a
beaucoup dit que vous étiez le jean
gabin un jeune est ce que vous êtes
aussi cet avis bah c'est pas moi je suis
un gamin quand il était jeune j'ai
trouvé formidable la région je préfère
être le monde au brésil est belmondo non
pas que parce que je trouve pas gayral
bien dans le camping était jeune c'était
jean gabin et je voudrais garder votre
personnalité hier nous avons assisté en
effet à une scène tournée où vous étiez
au milieu de la rue oui vous nous
raconter ce qui se passe exactement
magisto ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure ce personnage qu'un petit bois
rosiers avec l'espagne est là elle a
vraiment beaucoup bu et se prend pour un
tas d'or est la voiture hybride
pour lui ce sont les taureaux et tous
les bateaux qui étaient rassemblés pour
lui c'est la reine
vraiment il s'y croit vous avez joué
dans beaucoup de films vous avaient
campé un prêtre un mauvais garçon le duc
de lauzun un personnage historique
est ce que maintenant si vous vous
donnez à choisir entre un personnage
historique entre un prêtre et un mauvais
garçon et que ces trois propositions
arrivent en même temps que choisit
arrive pas choisir est celui qui me
semblent aura lieu point de vue sujet et
pointu rôle qu'ils soient mauvais gentil
mais est ce que vous préférez
l'interpréter est-ce que vous avez
l'impression plutôt que le fait
d'interpréter un mauvais garçon colle
plus à votre peau que le duc de lauzun
par exemple donc pas du tout quand j'ai
tourné bout de souffle j'étais prêt asa
l'aise mais que je tournais les enfants
après j'étais à l'aise aussi et dans un
singe en hiver c'est également une
composition parce que c'est un
personnage quand même riche qui n'est
pas éthique arman raysse qui boit
beaucoup c'est aussi une composition et
je suis à l'aise aussi
moi j'aime bien justement j'y crois que
j'aurais du mal s'ils jouaient toujours
les mauvais garçons parce que ça
deviendrait exactement le petit j'allais
au bureau ou toujours des curés c'est
les choses qui pour nuire est est ce que
je trouve bien justement c'est de ce que
je voudrais faire plus longtemps
possible c'est de changer le plus facile
de personnages
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
jouer une pièce au théâtre pas attention
oui je voulais jouer cette année mais
c'est pas pu parce que je vais jouer
serré bernard la puce à l'oreille
comédie-française jouer le fil à la
patte
vous à tirer dans les pattes on dit que
vous êtes à l'heure actuelle la plus
grande vedette parmi les jeunes vous
êtes la vedette qui est demandé partout
qu'est la pression cela fait-il
puisqu'il ya combien de temps vous
faites du cinéma du cinéma j'ai je
commence à faire des petits rôles en 56
mais depuis que vous êtes jean paul
belmondo il ya combien de temps
j'entends champagne de nombreuses
vedettes de trois ans que la passion
cela fait-il
au bout de trois ans de voir que tout le
monde vous réclament que vous êtes
demandé à droite à gauche
bon c'est quand même près sur moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est très important
parce que je desborough c'est tout le
reste se voit pas tellement
quand je pense pas quand on vous propose
un personnage est ce que vous êtes très
difficile sur le choix du sujet est ce
que vous êtes en d'aller tout de suite
par la lecture d'un scénario où est ce
que vous demandez le temps de réfléchir
et vous relisez le scénario quelque
temps après à bas bruit toujours je
relis ça y est c'est ya pas le doigt ça
des fois on fait un film tout de suite
on est emballé mais par exemple et on
mort après comme l'a proposé j'ai relié
au moins trois quatre favoris des rouies
ça vous a pas paru un solide qu'on vous
demande d'incarner un traître vous que
si justement mais je voulais voir quels
gens parce que dans les pratiques et
plusieurs personnages aussi n'y est pas
prête que j'ai senti que je pouvais
faire et vous avez été dans les lieux
mêmes des prêtres-ouvriers vous êtes
n'avait jamais dans les en avant dans
les endroits où à mon âge je ne veux
jamais parce que je crois que je
t'aurais l'acteur c'est un acteur
d'avoir d'imagination je pense pas mal
mais sans caractère du programme libre
en stéréo non pas ça il ya des films
qu'on aime qu'on peut voir c'est plus
facile que d'incarner un prêt en don je
trouve pas je vous posais la question
classique
est-ce que vous avez des projets oui
lesquels bah après la jeu
répartir en italie- corbellini après je
serai sans doute les offert exhorté
caire après les défaire show est melvin
cas présent au japon puis après je me
reposer et bien je crois que ce sera un
repos bien gagner je vous remercie
beaucoup jean paul ii
[Musique]